[Music]
in high-reward news o submitted by Sean
for the win yay H it's a fan named Sean
win ya know Sean for the sound a lesbian
couple has been charged with neglect
after giving their son marijuana for
good behavior but why do they have to
emphasize the lesbian part because
they're lesbians but every time they say
lesbian porn [ __ ] me up because I see
two hot girls in bikinis with the kid in
marijuana just smoking weed giving it to
the kid I think he said lesbian because
usually you have the male figure as the
moral compass yeah two females making
decisions so they just agreed with each
other and now they're giving this kid
drugs because we all know all women
agree on everything
yep I guess we should split up and I
should just go to another airman what no
I'm your moral compass she won't say yes
woman I do cool I would love to see that
happen yeah I mean but you're not
anywhere in the picture you can extend
the marriage I mean if you want to make
it to your your cut out of this just do
including yourself double bubble trouble
yeah yes and it it's not like a I'll
give you a [ __ ]
whoa no no so with me and this world
we're gonna love each other and we're
gonna we're right in the middle of
yourself [ __ ] I just literally
pictured her having a serious company
like I want a divorce
and I want to leave this house and parts
like me in the middle like I met
somebody else well how are we house
gonna fit we only have one bedroom it's
like nope we're splitting up I can't
afford two homes that's like three
months later it's like stop coming here
it's not your house you don't understand
like how [ __ ] accurate that is those
are our fights a hundred percent pick up
the keys to a new house on Thursday I'm
leaving you and that's why they and
she's like I'm pregnant all right so
this couple here names are Melissa and
Susan they're both 36 I don't know how
old the kid is I tried looking
everywhere
Susan's ugly huh the only thing that I
do know is that this kid is weighed 100
pounds they gave us that information but
not B so we don't know how heaviest type
[ __ ] yeah that's like some junior high
age stuff Brian cuz he's 100 pounds that
he has to at least be six years old oh
really
I'll busy off on my way six no I was
like 85 pounds when I was like in third
grade no the big ass kid oh my god Wow
in third grade I only know that because
I still have the certificate from my
Taekwondo thing so it tells you the
weight class but you were competing in
oh that's what I was in take 135 pounds
- yeah I was like probably 60 pounds I
was probably 35 pounds and I don't even
know third grade other pretty big kid
though so this is a couple which one
Susan once a couple left I always like
when you see a gay or lesbian couple one
is the more boy gender stop necessarily
the one is the more lady genders not
true there's like thank you yeah even in
double lipstick there's not one that's a
little bit no boy your own oh well in
this photograph you've got lipstick on
I'm [ __ ] kidding all right you called
it I called it you're right an on Susan
is usually more [ __ ]
I knew some Susan's that were hot I know
Susan that's really good-looking but did
you see a birth certificate
what's her government name no it's
probably Susannah 'they they look like a
happy couple that wanna share let's send
her knows are so close together what the
[ __ ] cuz she smells some [ __ ] piss she's
smelling over there's no space so
melissa is the mother of this young boy
that's the only way they refer it to so
she's the biological ones to keep it and
then Susan okay Raun remo if she turns
that frown upside down it's a really big
smile yeah six inch or it's like legit
if somebody said it's a huge smile
am i doing it no no her frown is
ridiculous man I can't get a crease that
passes my lips that's an A+ frown dude
look don't that crease goes past
yeah they wave her she looks like a
Chilean sea bass like a bigmouth grouper
that's good her lips end right here
that means if she opens her mouth I
think is huge dude it looks like if she
opened her mouth you just see the back
of an airplane they look very similar to
the get insane actually that's weird it
has been scientifically proven that
giving like medicinal marijuana or
whatever to a developing brain is
terrible yeah it's very very bad you do
that to adults
yeah come on now [ __ ] that dolt
your brains already there so apparently
are you seeing marijuana's bad pal cuz
little developing brains yes
how old is a developing brain under what
is it 18 in I think it's up to 24 if
you're a male it's up to 24 well [ __ ]
like the safe marijuana like it's safe
for you to use marijuana I think I can't
remember the number anymore but then
that was like the one thing it was like
probably smoked every day from 13 to 17
and you live in your own world
I get it now damn 13 is 17 everything
but I quit early 17 issue and I got it
to eat the exact reason why is it happen
you mean it's a gateway drug really I
guess it is a gateway drug it was a
gateway drug for me right I did 13 to 15
everyday gateway drug is cigarettes Oh
pick picking up cigarettes on the floor
or whatever or whatever smoking that
[ __ ] is a weird drug in general because
it's not something that you use and you
get an immediate effect of euphoria you
don't mean you have to develop an
addiction for it then you like it no you
do you get that hey hit that head change
I mean it's not euphoric but you're like
I never saw one of the hope like when
they first started smoking in front you
know I don't even know why I liked it
when I started I was like this does
nothing but I can't stop doing it dude
sometimes I'm such a [ __ ] that I'll
smoke like meat who can be like like
it's like how the [ __ ] is that possible
blueberry hook that's crazy oh it's good
I love parently they gave this kid
marijuana 50 times within the 90-day
period that's a lot how much good kid do
holy [ __ ] I took on the charge they
would punish him like if you would
misbehave they would punish him from not
getting that's a punishment yeah so then
apparently this there was this one day
where the girlfriend Susan pushed this
little kid to the ground and pinned him
to the ground
whoa damn he moving anyway no he's not
moving the son punched her oh [ __ ] you
feel it and then he was found by police
walking on the side of the road near the
home and that's when the boy told
investigators that but his mom and the
girlfriend would give him weed if he did
something good and would ground him from
weed if he was Miss B well we rat out
his own person because he was pissed
after that point every not going to get
weed anymore buddy don't [ __ ] roll on
your own both
maybe they really suck then because you
were like fighting each other
delete advocates dude for some for a
drug that's supposed to mail you out
there so hyper aggressive like being the
like weed everything like I had a
conversation recently where I don't like
we cuz I just don't like some stuff that
it makes me not myself like I don't like
the way it feels and so like but I am
interested in using like THC oil just
cuz we've been I've been training a lot
and I'm [ __ ] sore all the [ __ ] time
my leg you know saw like oh you mean DVD
I already do ya CBD or not TCO so CBD
oil yes a CBD oil right so I'm like okay
well let's try that out it might it
might help out I heard it like it helps
you sleep to or whatever without the
psychosis effects and so I was like yeah
I'm willing to try that you know so you
do like weed then and I'm like no I
don't those are two different things
like you like wheat for the hallucinogen
whatever those type of effects I'm
talking about a medicinal purpose that
I'll help me not feel like [ __ ] you know
like my joints hurt and [ __ ] like that
and so it was so weird just like having
a conversation with this guy about
something that's we related he goes so
you're not against me I never said I was
against we well unfortunately like
everything right there are extremists
like I new guy
back on our to maker studios and he was
just religious about weed like he was
like he was like we're talking about
he's like it takes you to a [ __ ]
molecular level of your existence that
allows you to truly see the world as it
exists and not as the bullsháá that we
all have before us and it's like I feel
like that we're just like dude like
you're so [ __ ] annoying
yeah like stop pushing weed on me man I
don't care I'm gonna smoke with you man
cuz you're so annoying I don't want to
be like you I want Kim I want to keep
finding you annoying and not be like
[Laughter]
because he's like the worst weed
ambassador do I I don't want to turn
into you so you're not doing with weed
any favors exactly but I know some
people who are the sickest people I've
ever known who smoke weed all the time
yeah yeah so it's just like there's but
there's always the [ __ ] it's like the
religious people who are like well
you're going to hell and I just hope I
can save you in time it's like oh just
[ __ ] all their bad brand ambassadors
exactly and sometimes like my personal
pain I think we just doesn't mix well
with people you know and so it's just
like for me like when I when I took the
edible to help me sleep I did like it
you know and they're like well you
didn't do it the right no I just don't
like it how come I can't just like it
now that's like
you alcohol huh I could just not like it
but I'm still gonna make you drink
alcohol and so make you love it part
into it yeah you cracked is that my dude
I can't get into extra things he tried
man in Vegas he really did give it a
shot he really did and he went to bed at
8:30 that's a bar I didn't drink at all
those boys stayed out all night with you
that's right you guys look the same
you look good why would you sleep early
and in NGOs like oh you guys don't ow oh
yeah I remember he always drags me down
I told you to go out with them you
should've disavow he says it you can go
oh I like this but then we all won like
a granite craft so you missed out cuz
how I feel it was like this was what
Bart was like this baby you really loved
me I'd watch this
yeah part dozen want me to go out like
whining complaining or just won't let me
go grab his arm it puts it on earth get
off me babe well you're right Joe what
the [ __ ] does this have to do with being
lesbians yeah no nothing
love how people do that it's not like
every articles like straight couple
found to be in trouble yeah what the
[ __ ] as irrelevant as like two [ __ ]
obese people [ __ ] feeds marijuana to
kill the subtext of like see lesbians
raising kids bad because the title
should have been two of the ugliest
women I've ever seen in my life yes it
gives way to yes lady with the biggest
frown yeah yeah hard prop the world's
biggest frown I would have clicked on
that right away
[Music]